¿Es el punto 2, 5 una solución de este sistema?
Y aquí tenemos dos desigualdades,
"y" es mayor o igual que "2x" más 1
y "x" es más grande que 1.
Y aquí queremos ver si el punto 2,5
es solución de este sistema,
es decir, lo que tenemos que hacer es sustituir el valor de "x" por 2 y el valor de "y" por 5
en ambas desigualdades para ver si
realmente llegamos a dos desigualdades verdaderas.
Así que de la primera,
lo que voy a hacer es sustituir a "x" por 2 y a "y" por 5,
entonces me queda que 5 es
mayor o igual que 2 por 2 más 1,
lo que hice fue meter un 2 aquí
en el valor de "x" y un 5 en valor de "y".
Y entonces me queda que 5 es
mayor o igual que 2 por 2 más 1,
lo cual es 5,
¿y esto es cierto?
Sí es cierto, porque 5 es igual a 5 y por lo tanto,
5 es mayor o igual a 5,
por lo tanto esto si lo cumple,
porque es igual.
Y bueno, vamos a ver si cumple también
la segunda desigualdad
y la segunda desigualdad
me dice que "x" es más grande que 1.
Por lo tanto, "x" en este punto vale 2 y 2
es más grande que 1 y esto también es cierto.
Y entonces puedo concluir que este punto,
2, 5 cumple ambas desigualdades,
lo que quiere decir que este punto es parte de la solución de este sistema.